Luke Tom and Nathan here with the
outdoor boys YouTube channel and today
we're going out and doing a wilderness
survival video yes
[Music]
and we're gonna see if we can survive in
the woods with our wits and our tools
and loads and loads of snacks for mommy
all right guys you ready to go do a
little hike let's let's go it's gonna be
far you can handle this hut two three
four
all right let's do it all righty you
guys keep it up yeah it's it's tough
over here oh can you can you keep up are
you okay we're gonna make it
don't give up boys rollway function
how's that they working good yeah that's
exactly what it was designed for all
right come on keep going we only have 15
more miles to go you're tired do you
know who else is tired the Donner Party
they were tired
y'all me chariot come on guys you hear
that hurry up
[Music]
we get outrun them Tommy I know your
legs broken and Nathan I know you've
been bitten by a rattlesnake but you
think we can keep going we can do this
you know that's a great idea
use hiking sticks alright guys shall we
set up the camp all right let's get the
tent down oh well check out my tent this
is a stingray hammock tent it's a three
person tent but it's a hammock so we're
gonna see how this goes I've never used
it before just got it off amazon.com and
I'll put a link in the description but I
got it mostly because I camp in a lot of
areas where we don't have flat ground
and because it's a hammock I can string
it up amongst the trees even if there's
not flat ground so like here you can see
we've got really sloped ground so yeah
nowhere to put a normal tent but
hopefully this will work
we'll find out warning do not use walls
fences street furniture roof racks or
posts as anchor points that seems really
specific I think that wasn't a
hypothetical
that looks like a rain fly okay the
problem I see so far is that the trees
have to be exactly an equilateral
triangle it's more than five degrees off
it doesn't work so you got to pick your
trees pretty carefully and if you want
to camp in a particular spot like in a
state-run campsite might not be
available so this is much more a
backcountry sort of no sort of thing
[Music]
[Music]
you guys like that stay off that hole in
the middle I don't yeah yeah I don't
think that's meant to hold little boys
so I think if you jump on that you're
gonna fall gonna tear it so don't jump
on the middle part would you guys help
me build a fire okay why don't you guys
look around and see if you can gather up
a bunch of sticks and make a big pile of
sticks on the fire pit good job good job
Tommy
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as we get done a pack in the bag
we'll get ready to go alright oh hey
look guys I forgot I totally forgot we
packed Jacob
oh good Jacobs here it's his first
camping trip there you go take him bad
guy you made it
I'm surprised you made it past the pack
of wolves they nearly got Nathan
today we're going ghetto fabulous folks
I didn't want to pack ketchup
so I got a bunch of chick-fil-a sauce in
here there we go we're gonna having for
having chick-fil-a hot dogs there yo dog
so you can see their eyes glowing in the
dark
raccoons up there you guys ready for fat
dad to come in all right guys you ready
to go to sleep all right let's do it
let's see if we can do this and I'll
give you guys an update in the morning
well guys I wish I had a better camera
because we're sitting here without the
rain fly on and guys what did you see up
at the sky that's right there's stars up
there is the first time you guys have
ever slept under the stars well all
right well how about this let's turn off
the light and let's count the stars okay
okay good guys well good morning
everyone
you sleep well Nathan yeah it sure does
he woke up screaming several times
did you guys hear the raccoons fight
last night definitely you fell asleep
the two of those raccoons just got into
a massive fight and they were spitting
and hissing and rolling around and they
went on for a while well now that we've
spent a night in the tent let me give
you my review first off I like the way
this thing is built it's really solid
good quality that party that your
brother's head downside to this though
is it's pretty heavy
it's for a three man tent it's a bulky
sucker and so if you're gonna be camping
or backpacking any significant distance
and weights an issue that might be be a
problem it's pretty roomy for a three
man tent
you know honestly mostly men tents are
only one man tents for for a big guy
like me I'm 6 foot 5 200
pounds this is this is pretty good if
you are looking for a tent to use in
warm weather this is the this is
absolutely perfect you've got full
ventilation at the top and you've got
loads of air coming up through the floor
because you're off the ground so this
tent will keep you cooler than just
about any other tent I can think of so
one downside the design is what to do
with all your loose stuff so they have
this pouch here in the middle and that's
okay but the problem is it's in the
middle we end up sleeping on it a little
bit that's the father of several small
boys one thing about this tent that
everyone seems to absolutely love is how
springy it is it's like sleeping on a
trampoline you guys like that it's
spring I mean how cool is that but
there's a bit of a learning curve to
setting this thing up you really need to
be able to to pick your trees right and
then if you ratchet one strap a little
bit then in the next one a little bit
then the next one a little bit and kind
of like tightening lug nuts on a car
tire just give yourself a little extra
time the first time you set it up and
you'll be okay what do you think of the
tent Nathan it's awesome Tommy do you
like the tent you know what I really
bought this hammock tent for was to let
us camp while fishing I like to do
overnight fishing trips and there's no
campsites and people don't really want
you clearing out brush and making
campsites and this will let me just
string up my tent between some trees and
we're good to go and it doesn't need to
be even ground
those boys sure love that thing it's
like a giant playpen you guys ready to
go get some breakfast okay check this
out here you guys can use the escape
hatch there we go well this has been fun
but I've got a very busy day today so
I'm gonna get the ten broken down get
everything back in the bags get the boys
home all good things must come to an end
one thing that's actually really
impressive about this design is very
little stretch in any of the material
this is a lot of force these ratchet
straps have put this under so this thing
is really tight and if you suddenly
release it and it was stretchy it would
spring back in your face and potentially
hurt you both all the boys jumping up
and down on the hammock I'm curious to
see whether it damaged the tree at all I
feel pretty good about that I don't
think that hurt the tree at all that
looks like it just knocked off some of
the loose bark but it didn't expose any
of the actual living wood
one of my big pet peeves with tents is
that the bags that they put them in are
so tight and small it's hard to get in
the tent back yet tight but it actually
got back into the bag without folding it
up properly
that's nice one naked camper Tommy are
you climbing a tree in your pajamas
you're climbing a tree naked thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor voice youtube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every week and
don't forget to hit that Bell button so
you'll get notified when we put out
another great video